محمد سامي 25 سؤال لازم نجاوب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير عمل صنع اسمك
ادم مين الاكثر نرجسيه انت او محمد رمضان
طيب كده كده واحد فيكم بس
ما حدش
طيب ايش اللحظه اللي قررت انك تتزوج فيها
مي عمر لاول مره شفتها اوف على طول اول
مره اوكي هل ممكن ترجع تشتغل مع الفنان
غاده عبد الرازق لا انت متهم انك من اكثر
المخرجين عصبيه وبتصرخ كثير في اللوكيشن
وبتشتم صح او غلط او كيف بترد ما بتشتغل
عشان الشغل بكون عايز الشغل يمشي بشكل
كويس فده بيعمل حاله من الاستراس لاني
مهموم الشغل اللي انا بعمله اوكي طيب عملت
تندم عليه
يعني في عمل بس ما تبي تقولوا اوكي
طيب اوكي يلا فنان او فنانه تعتقد انك لو
اشتغلت معاهم هتظهرهم بشكل مختلف عبله
كامل اهم نصيحه حصلت عليها
[موسيقى]
كثير بس يعني واحده بس ايوه واحده كده
دايما تتذكرها او تعتقد انها بالنسبه لك
عماد زياده قال لي لما جيت ارجع تاني بعد
الظرف بتاع الناس الاغراب قال لي يعني اما
ترجع ما تخليش في قلبك حقد او كراهيه او
اروح انتقام خلي عندك حب طيب قضيه ترغب في
تسليه الضوء عليها
[موسيقى]
كل كل بحب قويات اللي لها علاقه يعني بحب
اي قضيه لها علاقه بالمراه هي قضيه لها
علاقه بحقوق المراه واحترام المراه او
معامله المراه بشكل احسن او تمكينها اكتر
في المجتمع ممتاز ليش دايما بيقال انه
عندك مشاكل كثيره مع الناس لا والله ابدا
هو بس دايما الحياه لما بيكون الواحد
حياته موجود حواليها ان هو معروف او مشهور
بيحصل خلاف الخلاف دوت بيتبروز بشكل كبير
قوي فبيحسس الناس ان هو خلافات كتير بس هو
خلافات مع الاشخاص انا بشتغل الشغلانه
الواحده بيكون معي حوالي 700 بني ادم ما
بين فنانين وما بين فنانين اكيد مش كل
الناس هيتفقوا علي ومش كل الناس هتتفق
معهم يمكن انا كمان في وقت وانا اصغر كان
في ضد افعالي بتكون اعنف فبكبر المشكله
دلوقتي اعتقد اننا في المرحله العمريه
مختلفه مين اشطر محمد سامي المخرج او
المؤلف
محمد سامي المؤلف شغال عند محمد سامي
المخرج
فالمخرج يعني هو الاشطر اللي بيتحكم
محمد سمير المخرج بيالف اهم شيء نفسك
تعلموا البناتك
وربنا سبحانه وتعالى
اخراج الاغاني المصوره ما بيعتبر تقليل من
موهبتك
انا بدات فيها انا بدات فيها انا تعرفت
عشان انا مخرج الاغاني المصوره وحتى ده
اللي عرفني للناس اي حاجه انا بحترمها طول
الوقت بدات بها اوكي وممكن ده حلو احد
مثلا مطرب كلمك مثلا ممكن تعملها حسب هو
مين يعني انا عملت كده من قريب كذا مره بس
حسب هو مين اكيد لكل مرحله لها شغل ينفع
تعمليه شغل لا اجمل
الاتزان ده هو احسن حاجه فيها اوكي اصعب
موقف مر عليك
موت اختي الله يرحمها الله يرحمها طيب
اعمال محمد سامي ناجحه ولكنها تجاريه
وللاستهلاك السريع وليست للزمن كيف بترد
اعمال محمد سامي للاستهلاك السريع ما كناش
بقيناه فاكرين الاسطوره لغايه دلوقتي ما
كناش بقينا فاكرين البرنس لغايه دلوقتي ما
كناش فاكرين ادم لغايه دلوقتي سبق الوزراء
لغايه دلوقتي لا العمل الاستهلاك ده ده
بيقول له الحاجات ديت الناس اللي بتكون
زعلانه او ما حققتش نفس النجاح فبتحاول
تقلل من نجاح الاشخاص انما كلام مش مظبوط
مين اهم مخرج مصري في اخر خمسين سنه
في اخر خمسين سنه لا هو في كتير قوي هو ده
سؤال يعني يترد عليه ما ينفعش في 25 سؤال
ده سؤال عايز لوحده ساعه ونص لوحده عشان
نقول عندك
كتير اتعلمت منهم كلهم ازاي افضل فيهم حد
عن التاني كل واحد اتعلمت منه حاجه وانواع
مختلفه مش كلهم بيقدموا نفس الحاجه مصر
بلد العظماء مصر بلد المخرجين العظماء كل
اساتذتي وكل زمايلي عظماء كلهم فما اقدرش
انقي شخص واحد منهم باظلم للاخرين او عدم
احترام للاخرين مصر فيها اساتذه كتير اقوى
جمله كتبتها
كل واحد بيشوف الناس من عين طبعه
لسه بقى بتقول ما مانع اعمل مع محمد سامي
في عمل ولكن عمل ليس فيه ما عمر كيف ترد
ربنا يكرمها ويوف
قه واضح انه مش حتشتغل معك لو عمل فيه مي
عمر ولا عمل ما فيه ما يعمر لو في دوره
هيناديها اكيد انا بحترم الناس والموهبهم
يعني لو في اي دوشه اكيد اجيب ايه علاقه
ده تقول اللي هي عايزه تقوله اكيد ده مش
يعني مش مركز مع اللي هي بتقول بصراحه
اوكي هل الناجح في مصر محارب في مصر
[موسيقى]
ام كلثوم من نجح في مصر عبد الحليم النجاح
في مصر عادل امام النجاح في مصر
احمد حلمي النجاح في مصر دايما بيدعم
الناجح في العالم كله الحاقدين بيحاربوه
انما النجح في مصر بيدعم من الشعب ومن
الدوله ومن الفنيين بيحاربوا في العالم
كله اوكي طيب فيلم او مسلسل كنت اتمنى لو
كان لك
فيلم او مسلسل اتمنى لو مسلسل اي مسلسل
استاذ محمود عبد العزيز رحمه الله عليه
الله يرحمه ايه لو فيلم اي فيلم استاذ
عادل امام رحمه
يا رب
يعني الاستاذ عادل امام والاستاذ وحيد
حامد رحمه الله
متى اخر مره بكيت
تقريبا في الحلقه
لا اخر مره بكيت وانا بمنتج لسه من قريب
في مشهد بتاع محمد رمضان واحمد فهيم وانا
اديت مع استاذه العظيمه غاده عز الدين
وانا قاعد بتفرج على السين افطر
هل صحيح انك تكتب او لما تكتب دائما
بتتخيل انه بطله العمل هي مي عمر حتى لو
ما كان العمل لها طبعا لان انا بكتب
بطريقه مؤلف غريبه شويه انا بكتب بطريقه
مخرج فيجوالايزر ببص بتفرج وبشوف فدائما
بشوف الفيديوهات هي البطله اللي بشوفها هي
البطله حياتي كلها اللي هي مي عمر اصعب
مشهد صورته
في حياتي ولا في العمل الاخير
اصعب مشهد صورته
[موسيقى]
طب اصعب معلش انا عارف ان هو 25 سؤال بس
اصعب من حيث ايه اصعب من حيث المجهود ولا
اصعب
ممكن نفسيا كان عليك صعب ممكن مشهد يعني
كان منحوس بشكل رهيب مشهد كمجهود وانا
بصور الاغاني بتاعه مسلسل لؤلؤ
الاغاني كانت كل اغاني مي ونرمين الفقي
وكل الاستعراضات كانوا في يومين على
كرومات وفيهم شغل جرافيكس كتير جدا كان
اصعب يعني كان يومين مش قادميين يعني طيب
شو المسلسل طلع حلو
طيب هل محمد سامي المخرج الاعلى اجرا في
مصر معرفش لا انا ما اعرفش اقول زمايلي
وانا يعني معرفش في موضوع الاجور ده يعني
حاجه لها علاقه بالارز وكدا انا مش عارف
فعلا
والله يعني الحمد لله اللي بيرضيني ولا
بيخلي بيتي ماشي بشكل كويس والحمد لله انا
مبسوط به بس يعني حاجه حاجه هتقول لي طب
بيني وبينك على راسي
شكرا يا محمد كانوا سريعين